[Music]
our memories Define
us they shape who we
are they guide how we
Act
they connect us to the
world but how well do we understand the
Pathways in the brain by which memories
are imprinted Consolidated and later
retrieved how does emotion affect the
things we remember and will science ever
gain the capacity to Tinker with our
memories implanting new ones and erasing
things we'd rather
forget and how does the unconscious mind
interface with conscious
memories these are but a few of the deep
questions that scientists investigating
the mind and memory are vigorously
exploring award-winning Professor
Christine alberini is one of the fields
leading
lights Dr alberini is a chaired
professor of neuroscience at New York
University where her work focuses on the
molecular and cellular mechanisms
underlying the formation storage and
retrieval of long-term
memories thank you so much for joining
us you know in in common language when
we talk about memory in informal terms
you often think of it as this like
singular monolithic quality
characteristic of the brain that it can
make memories but of course there seem
to be many different kinds of memories
from the point of view of experience
right we have things that we just
automat ically remember tying our shoes
how a chew there are abstract things
that we just know about like the meaning
of time and a year or a cat or a dog
there are experiential memories episonic
memories of things that we've
experienced in our day-to-day lives is
there a taxonomy of memories that helps
us organize the different types of
memories
absolutely uh there are ways to
uh distinguish memories in and classify
them for example according to the
duration we have shorter memories and
longterm memories and we all experience
that shortterm memories they last for a
few seconds or minutes longterm memories
they last for days weeks months even a
lifetime and we all remember events
single events that happen to us for
sometimes the rest of our life those
obviously are special specially longterm
memories and we will discuss about that
uh another ways to classify them is
according to the system the so-called
memory system that processes the
information meaning the learning the uh
uh formation of the longterm Memories
the storage the retrieval and so on and
there are different memory systems uh
two main ones are classified as
implicit and explicit memory systems and
in the explicit memory systems we have
the memories that we recall
consciously so if we are here and we
memorize today and tomorrow we can talk
about it with our friends or a week from
now or a month from now those are
conscious memories meaning they require
Consciousness when we recollect them
those are part of the explicit memory
system uh in those we have
autobiographical Memories We have uh
spatial Memories We have episodic
memories and part of those are also the
semantic memories conceptual memories
memories of some abstract concept so
when I say a dog you all know what I
mean but you are not thinking of one
specific dog perhaps you think about one
specific dog in an episodic type of
memory a memory of an episode of your
life with those details that specific
dog in that context and so on but the
concept of dog which is a abstract
concept comes from learning and is
memorized so those are also different
type of memories also belonging to the
explicit memory system then we have the
implicit types and those in those we
have many I'm not going to go into all
the classifications but the general uh
definition of implicit memories is those
memories that when they are recalled
they are recalled in an automatic way
without Consciousness so we just for
example the memories of how to do things
how to tie our shoes how to ride the
bike and so on and so forth so those
memories are recalled in an un conscious
way they're automatic we do those action
automatically so that is the one of the
major distinction between the different
types of memories according to memory
systems memory system means the system
that in our
brain process those type of information
in terms of
learning uh storing the information
recalling the information rearranging
the information in the present in order
to change update The Memories We
constantly update our memories so we're
going to dig a little deeper in just a
little while but before we do that just
from a more overview sense I think
everybody can understand the distinct
kinds of memories that you just alluded
to how well do we understand the way the
brain processes the information that
must be distinct presumably for these
distinct types of memories do we each
pathway that's a very good question we
actually don't
know uh the mechanisms and now I'm
talking about referring more to the
biological mechanisms so cell biology
molecular biological mechanism genetic
mechanisms involved in these
memories uh the stud is at this level
are quite young it's they started in the
late late 80s early 90s last century so
we're talking about 30 40 50 years if we
consider really the very very beginning
it's a very young field and during the
first 10 years it was very difficult to
get to
identify what are the molecular
mechanisms of longterm memories and so
what the field has done is to use very
simple systems invertebrate system sys
like a seil called aesia C fornica or
the fruit fly dropil melanogaster those
are two systems that have been very
useful to inform Us in terms of the
genetics and the molecular mechanism of
memory from the very early days and from
that understanding then the field went
on to into studying molecular and
biological mechanism in more complex
systems because nothing was known so it
was very important to start from very
simple systems where the number of
neurons is very
limited where the tools to ask questions
are uh easier because the system is is
very simple and would you say that
there's strong
evidence that the mechanisms the
pathways by which memories are formed
are similar across all life on earth
right so I was get into that sorry for
the long introduction but yeah so from
that uh then the field went into asking
whether those mechanism found in those
systems are also used by more complex
systems meaning different memory systems
in more complex
organisms and it it has not been very
easy to get the comprehensive
understanding of the mechanisms
characterizing the different systems so
we just started from what we knew from
the simple system and just ask the
question are those used also in the more
complex systems which means we are
looking we are getting what we ask we
are asking whether the same mechanism
are used so we're getting that type of
answer yes they are but so many others
which are
distinctive which are not completely
known are certainly to be discovered I
mean is it a challenge that the fruit
fly can't respond to questioning
they
can no definitely you know there are
simple memories that are tested and uh
and you we we have to consider the
question in the evolution right yeah and
so one type of memory that is
evolutionarily conserved is is or are
memories that are important for
survival one of the major question of
memory is to make sure we remember
something that is dangerous so that we
don't do it again and we put ourself in
danger all the time so if we memorize
that and those systems are very very
strong uh then we protect ourself from
danger or from you know disappearing for
for decreasing the decreasing the
possibility that the species Will
Survive so it's survival simple survival
that is present in drosophila in the
fruit fly in apesia in all the simple
systems in the sea Elegance in the worm
and uh as as much as in humans and do
you have a a clear understanding of the
survival value of each of the kinds of
memories that you're referring to
because clearly if you remember a
dangerous episode in your own past
you're less likely to repeat it which is
something that will enhance your
survival pass your genes for doing that
onto the Next Generation and so forth
but what about memory that is more for
personal identity as opposed to directly
for survival is it a byproduct of The
evolutionary process or is it just
something that complex neurological
systems are able to do it's just one of
those things that happens the the way I
see it is everything is coming from
an
important uh an important requirement
From
Evolution um so memories are clearly
essential functions for survival and for
everything we do every day so one is to
protect ourself from danger but the
other one is to find the best resources
for the most adaptive behavior that
every day we have to
do uh in that there is
also
what memory does to each individual
which is creating a system that is very
individualized and it is very
individualized because we learn every
day in different ways in different
context so why this individualization is
important in evolution is that if we are
transported in in another place in a
different context where we have to adapt
to that
context and we're going to do that
through learning we have to be able to
do so so in other words we are who we
are because of our memories memories in
in the large sense implicit and imp
explicit types memories that change
every day that uh change according to
the new experience so we have a lot of
um um storage of information recall of
information and then new learning in the
context of what we have learned and this
happens throughout life just think for a
moment what will be your life without
memories it cannot exist simply it
cannot exist so it's an essential
function but it works in a way that
every day we are learning something new
and we place that new information into
the history of our system and that is
the memory meaning the storage of
information and and of course there are
pernicious diseases which Rob us of
memories do you think of those at all in
an evolutionary sense because after all
if memory is
evolutionarily part of our strategy for
survival after we pass the age of
reproduction the disintegration of
memory should have no impact and why
would the body wake waste energy on
preserving these memories when it
doesn't need to preserve you for
survival any longer is is is that a
useful way of thinking yeah that's and I
don't have the answer for that right
because if we think about Evolution and
survival after we reproduce what's the
use of it but I I would think uh that
the use is to help the group the species
to be in a better
adaptive uh context
so this um and this is you know there is
no realove for that but logically we can
think that in groups we
create conditions that are more adaptive
or can resolve certain problems that we
Face uh in a different way than the just
the individual would do sure so that
that would be my answer yeah um and it's
important to think about memories
throughout life at different ages
because they're different so memories of
a newborn learning a memories in a
newborn clearly are very different than
learning a memory when we grow up and we
are at a different age but still very
young or adolesents or young adults or
middle age or aged and each of these
stages clearly comes with different
biology so what we are very interested
in studying is the biology that changes
throughout different ages and how this
biology is used by the memory system to
create new memories to recall old
memories to uh create new learning in
the history and adoptive so digging down
on that if we can just maybe do an
example almost an ex exercise so
everybody in this room is
experiencing the conversation that we're
having hopefully it's forming Memories
We hopefully long-term memories so it
doesn't just go out of mind an hour from
now if that is happening inside the
brain of either a person watching this
live or digitally can you take us
through in Broad brush or microscopic
detail whatever you choose what's
actually happening inside the head of
someone who is forming a memory of our
conversation right so memories of an
episode like this will become
longterm if they are important to you if
they're important to you it means that
there is an
arouser it means that some hormones and
neurotransmitters that are important for
processing attention arousal excitement
are released in the brain so those
systems talk to the memory systems so
other networks of cells not only
neurons you know neural science is very
centered on neurons which is rightly so
however there are many other types of
cells in the brain and they all
cooperate for all these processes that
happens so what happens is that these
hormones uh and and systems that
modulate the memory systems themselves
so the network of cells that store
uh and storage actually I'm going to go
back to this that store the information
long term they create biological changes
over time it takes time to form memory
so this memory that you form today no
matter how longterm it's going to be uh
but let's say it will be a longterm
memory uh is not now stored in a strong
way right now there is a representation
of what's going on here here which is
actually fairly detailed because you
know what I'm saying what Brian is
asking who is around you uh you see the
details of the room and so on and so
forth but this is not the longterm
memory that will last a number of
changes happen in the brain based on
biological activation of Pathways for
example there is gene
expression transcription and translation
those are the two major mechanism in
biology transcription of genes
translation of mrnas are essential for
longterm memories so the way we
distinguish longterm memories from
shortterm memories is by looking at
whether they require transcription and
translation this is a Hallmark of
longterm memories so transcription
translation happens in our circuitry of
memory circuitry of episodic type of
memories one major region involv is the
HP
hampus but the hippocampus cross talk to
many others cortical regions and other
regions they get the input or the
regulation the modulation from amigdala
for example uh from other areas of the
brain that tells that this is an
important event to memorize and all
those molecular changes in all those
brain regions they change over time the
first 24 hours are very important but
they continue to happen for days and in
some cases also weeks weeks that meaning
that the hippocampus and cortical
regions for example
reverberate keeps talking to each other
and all that biology that occurs over
all this time is essential for forming
longterm memories if there is an
interruption of those mechanisms
longterm memories are not going to be
formed the the earlier the interruption
is the disrupt ition the more the
longterm memory will be absent will be
disrupted uh so there the uh in other
words there is a a Cascade of molecular
events that happens in the brain that
over time create a stable representation
and this stable representation changes
as I mentioned over time and over weeks
it shifts from certain regions to others
until it Bec this memory is called
Consolidated so in other words memories
are fragile when they're form over time
they consolidate once consolidation is
completed the memory is stable and if we
try to interfere with the molecular
mechanism there is no effect anymore the
memories now you mentioned transcription
and translation as a vital part of going
from short-term memory to longterm
memory and so that's the production of
certain proteins presum ably do we
understand how the production of those
proteins are essential to the memory
moving to the longterm phase do do we
understand that well at the molecular
level well is is too much it's pushing
it okay but certainly this was one of
the questions that started as I
mentioned in the late 80s to understand
what molecules what genes are expressed
to form longterm memories what proteins
are made where do they go what do do
exactly in the brain uh for how long is
this are these mechanisms involved and
so on and so forth and and of course we
have addressed some of the questions but
not all of them so there is this Cascade
of gene expression so a number of genes
are transcribed and then translated into
proteins there are also many other
levels of Regulation chromatin changes
of course when there is gene expression
there is also chromatin
changes uh and uh also the uh
transcription of rnas that are not
translated into proteins but regulate a
number of steps so there are there is
there are so many steps at at the
biological level that converge into a
Cascade of
mechanisms my lab as many others have
focused on the which transcription
factors and and Gene trans genes are
transcribed in the brain in these brain
regions which are required for long-term
memories and many others have looked at
the translation of this mRNA so we and
others of course have identified a
number of mechanisms of Pathways that
are essential for longterm memory
information longterm memory storage as
well as uh whether they are re-involved
when we recall memories that's another
interesting I wanted to ask you about
that because from from an experience IAL
standpoint just anecdotally when I've
wanted to remember something long term
even when I was a student what I would
do is 15 minutes before the next lecture
I would review the previous lecture and
I found just by reimagining and
rethinking about the material from the
previous it just stuck in a way that was
more potent for me than cramming it in
at the end and when I have to you know
give some kind of presentation I want to
remember this or that I find just a
little 10-minute reminder every single
day is what makes it go from short to
long is is that consistent with your
understanding of how long-term memory is
formed it is it is we have studied what
recalling memory uh
does when we recall memories of course
is you know uh intuitively we recall
memories because we need we need to do
something we need to make a
decision uh but what happens in the
memory system and why is this recall
important yes and it is important as we
found to strengthen memories but clearly
the recall is not as the learning
event so it's a
different uh processing of the memory is
not exactly
strengthening uh completely the memory
that we originally had in the learning
event but we recall and perhaps is a
partial recall and that is strengthening
the memory this is is is also what we
found but when uh this was studied in
terms of molecular mechanism it became
very interesting because so as I
mentioned longterm memories required
gene expression and it was believed that
once memories consolidated
is no longer uh sensitive to disruption
or
changes uh of course it can be change
with new learning uh but a number of
studies show that when memories are
recalled they become fragile again for a
limited temporal
window uh similar to what happens with
no learning and during the temporal
window again they require transcription
translation to stabilize in other words
there is a reconsolidation ation
happening with the retrieval the recall
of the memory so a memory recall can be
dangerous then in a way this doesn't
happen with all the memories and all the
time but it happens and so it can be
dangerous right so why should it be if
it is
dangerous why actually does it happen
nature doesn't work that
way it happens because with that
fragility we can actually strengthen the
memory so it is a way it's like a
tradeoff memory it's a tradeoff you you
go into a danger zone of modifying or
losing the memory but the upside is by
undergoing this process you strengthen
it if it survives in most cases you will
not lose it you have to interfere yeah
in order to lose it in other words no
learning could do that could interfere
and this is why memories are not precise
because constantly we recall memories we
have some new learning coming in uh and
Al decays of memories forgetting is
another process of memory of course very
important we need to
forget uh so all the combination of
these
creates the the way memories work but
they cannot be precise because we
constantly change them so another way
through which these recall dependent
changes work uh is to incorporate new
information into the old old
representation so we recall and now we
associate something new to that uh so
this uh uh mechanism or process is
called reconsolidation it has been
studied quite a bit it generated a lot
of interest particularly if we want to
think about uh for example diseases like
post-traumatic stress disorder or
addiction yes where the memories are
very
strong memories of trauma and there're
also very distinct right they're
distinct from normal
memories uh postraumatic stor addiction
the memories of how the uh substance
feels is very much connected to
context people who are addicted relapse
when they go back to the old context
because the memories of it make them
relapse so there was a lot of interest
when this reconsolidation and temporal
window of intervention let's call it uh
emerged because the field thought well
it could be an interesting approach to
actually decrease the strength of those
memories and help the process of
therapeutic so I don't remember the
mechanism in Eternal Sunshine of the
Spotless Mind but was that the basic
idea that they were restimulating the
memory and getting in there and somehow
ering exactly like that it is exactly
like we see this in in in the lab so if
we take an animal we use we work with
rats and mice with rodents we take an
animal they learn something and then we
make them recall that memory and during
the temporal window of reconsolidation
we
intervene with it can be in different
ways to interfere with the
reconsolidation process uh they they
forget not that they forget they lose
the memory because they cannot
reconsolidate it so the they can't run
through the maze anymore or something
like that the memory decreases wow now
you you you also made reference to
emotion being an important part of
long-term memory formation so and then I
don't mean this to sound factious but
I'm actually wondering so you know if
I'm studying general relativity I'm at
my desk and I'm usually pretty calm as
I'm going through the ideas in the
equation say but if I was to somehow be
much more excited and and emotionally
disturbed or or in some friends you said
is there a better chance that I will
remember the material in a longterm way
sure for sure but you know we know we
know that right even
caffeine right I'm I just I don't want
to
mention other stuff no feel free we're
yeah you know we already have this EX
examples throughout you know many years
we have we know that see I would have
always thought caffeine or artificial
stimulants were viewed and I'm learning
in this conversation they to me were
just focusing your attention more fully
because you're more awake but not
because you're emotionally aroused no
but attention is one way to increase the
uh storage of long-term Memories the
other is arousal as you say so is is a
similar is is a similar consequence yeah
this hormones can increase do increase
the biological changes as I was
mentioning happening in the memory
system which lead to morphological
changes in other words there is a
physical change in the brain in those
circuitry that store
memories as my advisor used to say I
train at Colombia with arand sure uh
after an event if you form a longterm
memory you have another Wrinkle in your
brain and um so just thinking about the
the wrinkles for a moment
um if one is trying to enhance longterm
memory which I think many of us want to
do I mean it's very frustrating you
learn something and then a week later
you you just can't grab a hold of it
what are the effects of other things
like like sleep or or dreaming does that
have an impact on our capacity to retain
information some people say study it
just before you go to sleep in order
that the brain can consolidate is is
that real is there evidence for that so
there are evidence the the most I I
think interesting evidence for students
is that do not Crown because in order to
form a longterm memory the brain needs
time as I said this is a a process of
biology that requires time memory
consolidation if you go right after your
learning with another learning
event another consolidation process
going to start then the brain is
confused you're not going to remember
well which is the first learning piece
or the second learning and these
experiments have been done more than 100
years ago shown right so that's called
retroactive interference if you go with
a second learning event to uh close to
the first one the two events are not
going to be remembered well in a
separate way so do not give
time now sleep is very important that's
very well known that if sleep or
circadian
rhythmicity is altered consolidation is
going to be impacted because those those
mechanism of circity and sleep they work
together with the consolidation process
the biology that I mention all that
Cascade
includes uh a number of modification
that happens through the Circadian
rhythm as well as what happens in sleep
where the representation is
replayed so this replay is important for
the consolidation so if you we disrup
not the biology is part of
these processes if we disrupt any of
these processes and we can go with a
biological mechanism or uh or new
learning or behavioral
approaches uh then we disrupt the
ability of the brain to form longterm
memories in the best way now can we
enhance memories we can we have found
molecular mechanisms that can do that
very nicely one example we have in the
lab is it's a small protein it's called
insulin like growth F Factor 2 igf2
insulin like growth factor 2 and igf2
belongs to a um family together with
another igf igf1 and
Insulin uh but these three proteins they
do very they have very different
functions and igf2 we discover to be
regulated in brain regions important for
longterm memory like the hippocampus
with
learning and to be required for longterm
memory formation in other words if this
production of igf2 that occurs in the
hippocampus with learning is
blocked longterm memories do not form so
it's required can you do it artificially
can you add and then we added so you can
deplete the system or you can add right
so then when we added
igf2 without interfering with anything
else just having the learning event the
memories will spectac ularly more uh
stronger and more longer lasting this is
in rats this is in rats and mice uh and
this small peptides protein can actually
be injected even systemically like
insulin can be injected subcutaneously
we can do that with igf2 and we have
these animals that have a super memory
very strong and long lasting significant
effect so then of course we became
interest Ed in studying memory
enhancement in the normal animals but
also whether this could be a potential
Therapeutics for memory disorders we
have an incredible need for novel The
Therapeutics that can work for memory
disorders and you've not tried on people
and we have not tried on people but I
started a company because the data that
we have seen in the lab are you taking
investors in this I do
okay
so this igf2
reverses not only cognitive impairment
so we in the lab we have tested aged
animals and the cognitive impairments
related to aging is reversed we tested
models of neurodevelopmental disorders
like autism Angelman syndrome is a
genetic neurodevelopmental
disorder and these are characterized by
cognitive impairments so we reverse the
cognitive impairments but also the other
problems that they have and that was
very exciting but also surprising I have
to say for example in Angelman syndrome
they have Motor problems in addition to
cognitive problems they have repetitive
behaviors like
autism uh they often have seizures and
with igf2 we reverse all of these so it
sounds like a miracle but it must be a
downside right exactly so we started ing
what are the downsides do we see for
example the memory that that are
potentiated in the normal animals are
they more rigid no they're not do we see
any obvious um uh effect side effect we
have not seen but of course these have
to be tested in a different ways if we
want to go to to uh to people of course
uh so so far it's really very exciting
what we see with this igf2 not only as a
cognitive enhancer in normal normal
individuals or normal animals but also
as a potential Therapeutics for a number
of diseases so what do they have in
common uh Aging for example aging
related cognitive impairment with
neurodevelopmental
disorders and other labs have studied
igf2 in Alzheimer disease models in
Huntington disease models and again all
beneficial effect with igf2 what do they
have in common they have in common that
they accumulate proteins in the brain
different type of proteins in different
diseases but the common problem is
protein accumulation in the brain so we
were very surprised to see all these
effects and of course went into studying
the mechanism for why this may happen
and it turned out that uh this
igf2 works through a re ctor that
regulates protein metabolism in other
words the making and breaking of
proteins and spits up protein
degradation that is the elimination of
proteins in the protein metabolism is
that like eliminating plaque is that a
different type of thing so that's what
we we want to do now we want to look at
WEA in the disease models we eliminate
those specific proteins let's say
Alzheimer disease models that we see
plaque elimination and so on and so
forth some studies already have shown
that that's the case with igf2 in the
mouse model yeah so it's very exciting
it sounds it um I want to just change
gears a little bit um one of the
interesting realizations in the last few
decades in the judicial system is how
unreliable eyewitness memory and
testimony can be H how do you view that
from a a neuroscience memory
perspective indeed we already touched
upon that memories are not
accurate uh I I think first of all from
from my personal point of view we have
to
distinguish between what happened and
the accuracy of memory right sure mean
if somebody comes up with something that
never happened is different than saying
oh I have seen that person that day in
that
place this is where memories are not
accurate because uh over time and uh and
many rounds of similar memories for
example if you return to this room 10
times you will confuse who was at which
time in this room and clearly this
information is going to be less and less
accurate as time passes so if I ask you
tomorrow you have a more accurate memory
but if I ask you a month from now or six
months from now the memory is going to
be less accurate considering that the
repetition and uh the uh amount of
information that we have to make sense
with uh and what we do uh you can
imagine how uh the information is uh
confused in terms of who is in a certain
place at a certain time and so this is
where the the memories are not
accurate we usually say you know if you
talk to your family about a New Year's
Eve together I don't know some festivity
together and uh you start talking about
who was there and what was said there is
a complete disagreement about the
members of the family especially if the
the event was is dated right so over
time uh the information gets confused uh
and that's why the memories are not
accurate so yes they can be and do you
do you imagine that memories that are
say inaccurate or degraded or people
completely forget is the root
information still somewhere in the brain
I mean like a Freudian perspective would
say it's always there it's always
influencing you even from times that you
don't even consciously remember is that
a kind of Freudian myth or is there
evidence that everything that's ever
happened to you is somehow stored
someplace and is affecting you in some
manner yeah so I don't know I don't know
how to answer that question the the
fredian the fian essence though to me is
different I actually at one point in my
life uh trained as a psychoanalyst so I
started as a biologist I'm a bio
molecular biologist and I keep doing
that but at one point I I studied as a
psychoanalyst and
that that Essence to me and this is what
in influenced my studies in the lab
actually comes from
development so we're switching a little
bit gears here it's not this everything
is in our brain and everything we do is
long is stored long term and that it can
appear later I think actually the uncons
ious but this is my interpretation I
think the unconscious that frud is
talking about that influences our life
throughout uh comes from development the
way we learn from day one even
before the learning that happens through
development is shaping the brain and the
systems and I have started to study that
that's why I became interested in
studying the biology of learning and
memory in infancy so we take infant rats
and mice and look at the biology when
they learn and what we found it was also
very uh interesting and not predicted so
we we went into the question without any
mindset what we found is that in fact
the brain in infancy is learning to
learn for a certain temporal window
and in that temporal window it's like a
critical period it's a critical period
that's exactly it uh in that critical
period the system is developing and
shaping according to the experience that
the animal
has That's the basis of individuality so
it's not the specific details of the
memory it's rather how the experience
shaped the way the brain will
subsequently function and it's open to
that influence during this critical
period right and in fact we see that the
learning that they have in infancy
creates what we call a schema because
it's something that influences adult
behavior and it influences in a way that
the first the memory can be um
reinstated I'm going to get back to that
the infant memory and secondly uh it
influences similar types of behavior and
this happens only with the learning
during that critical period so the
reason why we we concluded that there is
a critical period is because we tested
it uh when we started to look at this
biology uh it was believed that learning
in
infancy uh is
forgotten and this is true so what do
you remember of the first three years of
your
life but this is normal so this rapid
forgetting that happens in this phase of
infancy is believ to explain what's what
is called infantile Amnesia the fact
that as adults we don't remember the
first few years of
life the theories and what was known at
that time when we started to investigate
this they were suggesting that
consolidation doesn't work because the
memory system that uses the campus is
not developed the campus is not involved
it's
offline uh so we started to give these
infant rat mice learning events and then
tested whether the memories could come
back so that was the first question
right if it's gone it's not going to
come back we were able to see it coming
back coming back it comes back so the
the animal forgets because when you test
them they they show no memory like
humans
there is a very rapid forgetting no
memory but if you then later on test
them with certain type of reminders you
can get the memory back and you knew the
specific reminder cuz you set up the
situation witho yes but we tested a
number of them before for us we wouldn't
know how to do that but no we don't know
and also it's unclear whether those
memories that come back are
conscious meaning they're conscious when
they come
back but do are they conscious about
when they will learn we have no way to
test it my view now is that those are
implicit type of representation implicit
type of memories not explicit I see that
however later on they are recalled
reactivated with some new learning or
some reminder and then they create the
expression of the explicit memory but
the infuence what we do they influence
what the animal does in adulthood for
example we didn't test in the old age
but up to adult for sure I can say that
so the reason why we we concluded is a
critical period is because we tested the
biology in of that
hippocampi and found that molecular
mechanisms that we're identified by
other studies in the sensory system as
mechanism of critical period are used by
our system the memory system to form
these longterm memories that are not
expressed but they can return and they
influence adult Behavior that's that's
kind of amazing um unfortunately we only
have a couple minutes left I wanted to
ask you a few more questions just to get
your quick thoughts on these issues I
think many of us have had the experience
that music is an incredibly powerful way
of bringing us back to an emotional
state at some earlier time in our lives
do we understand why music has that
capacity uh here is out of my uh
expertise but there are group studying
music and how that influences brain
activities and how that influence why
you know we have this uh why we have
this very strong recall with emotion is
because music is a CU and that is
processed by
amigdala uh so there is a representation
that is directly linked to the
emotional uh systems basically but more
than this I I cannot really say because
it's not what I'm studying but yeah
there are several studies going on with
so so another question that may fall
into that category if you don't mind so
some of the greatest literature has
explored human memory in in various
aspects and approach is there is there a
book out there that you consider to be
one that really in an Artful way
captures the the Wonders and Mysteries
of memory is there anyone that comes to
mind unfair questions so no no I would
not even mention any because there are
you know I would say there are several
with different from different angles and
different ways um yeah sure and a final
thing you know the world is extremely
excited about artificial intelligence
now and you know it's a wideopen Arena
but do you see those developments
interfacing or intersecting with the
kind of work that you do on the natural
version of intelligence and memory uh
they're
already working together together uh so
artificial intelligence is very much
involved for example computational work
is very much involved in understanding
now all the types of mechanisms that are
active in certain brain regions and how
do they change and so on and so forth so
data analysis because a lot of
approaches now they're not looking at
single mechanism they're looking at the
comprehensive pattern
so this is where computational comes in
uh there are other ways to manipulate
brain
circuitry uh again is engineering
certain uh
mechanisms and creating artificial tools
that can change the circuitry in the
brain and therefore behaviors the these
are just two examples but uh there is a
lot also done in terms of theories uh
that hopefully will inform experimenters
how to test new questions about
understanding the mechanism of memory
and can you imagine just oblique to that
but resonating with it will there be
brain machine inter faces that enhance
human memory is that a direction that
you see bearing fruit I don't know um I
mean in theory yes but I don't know how
easy that will be because
biologically uh considering the biology
of it which is where I come from the
brain constantly
changes and this
adaptability to whatever change comes in
the environment is very difficult to
recreate in a machine so we can create
circuitry we can create we we can plug
in a number of
information uh it can be extremely
sophisticated but how can we predict
something we don't know so that's that's
the bias I think yeah absolutely well
it's been a fascinating conversation on
memory across the various forms of life
with that capacity thank you so much and
please join me in thanking Christi
Al thank you so
[Applause]
[Music]
much
a
[Music]